[Music]
what is the craziest things
you've witnessed people do while people
watching
oh just this guy right here oh my god so
once
we were waiting uh to eat at this ramen
spot we were on the waiting list we have
to wait on the outside because the ramen
spot is so tiny
so me and bart were just chilling there
and above that restaurant there's like
this like
bar karaoke place like japanese place so
i see this old couple older couple they
look like they're in the 40 in the 50s
they uber or something there's a van
waiting for them the guy is [ __ ]
wasted like just imagine just an asian
dad completely wasted
the wife's carrying him because she's
more sober and stuff so she's like
holding him she sits him
in the back into the sliding door so
he's still getting in so he sits down
goes like this and then she goes she's
she throws the sliding door and you just
see his hands just he's like
and what was the aftermath he was just
like ah so then all these people are
trying to help open it
i think he did but it was a slow
reaction because he's so [ __ ] drunk
yeah and i was like what the [ __ ] just
happened so then
they open it finally he's like this and
then they just take off dang
it that's [ __ ] wild that's pretty
good
i don't know the first thing that popped
in my head was when we were all waiting
i think you guys were there too
we were all waiting outside of sugarfish
in downtown l.a and then
this random white guy starts walking or
like dragging his
cat on a leash oh he didn't even want to
be walked
it was just like dragging it he looked
kind of like a homeless guy
i thought that was really weird he was
dragging a cat
just didn't want to be there uh-uh
that's sad that was the first thing that
popped in my head so i'm sure i've seen
well
in this article a man was caught
sprinkling something on his diner food
in order to get out of paying the 90
tab what glass a fly
an insect pubes disgusting son of a
[ __ ] i knew it
because the like con artists they do
that [ __ ] why are you holding this
because i want a new wardrobe change
this is my box
i'm a box insect killer the same color
as your skin though
i was right what are you talking about
what
look at that look at that i knew it why
would he do it
as he's sitting at the table and not
like go to the back oh
[ __ ] gross bro oh
you're [ __ ] nasty he's salt baby
he's going for a second oh you're
[ __ ] gross
is going on that food salt baited is he
at a korean barbecue restaurant
he's at an indian restaurant wait what
this guy's
trash why would he do this so everyone
can see
i don't know why he scooted out like
like mad far or even table
i don't know do you know what's funny he
looks white right so like you got an
indian restaurant right and they're like
sir we don't have blonde people here
and all the poop cubes are blonde and
[ __ ] wow ah he doesn't look
white without because i mean he's
definitely is it across from his dad
no well the article says it's 220
something so they're both
roughly the same age like it looks like
he's way older this guy right here right
yeah he
looks like he has gray hair he's like 40
or 50. he looks white yeah
maybe just the way he wears his hat like
he also look yeah just the way he wears
his hat
kind of got that [ __ ] boy kind of like
yeah i don't know but yeah so
the article says they're two
20-somethings they walk into this
restaurant it smells like a gravy they
order
so much food 90 worth of food for two
people
and the waiters the whole entire staff
was like you know you're ordering like
a lot of food and just to let you know
you're not gonna be able to you know
it's just not for two people this is way
more than two people
and they're like no no we want this food
we want to eat like kings yup
and the food comes out they eat
apparently they're finished
and the next thing you know that's so
much food left over
i'm so glad that they had cameras they
need to change these [ __ ]
me too i think when this happens
the restaurant is allowed to lock their
doors
come out with spatulas [ __ ] them up
and then these guys have to be stripped
naked
and taken to the back and they have to
clean the whole restaurant
and they have to be tied down and you go
to all the cooks with their tongue
and have them shave all their pubes off
and go oh you like pubes
and everyone gets to sprinkle pubes on
their face no they're forced to eat it
yeah it so that could only happen once a
month then because then the cooks and
stuff have to let them puke
once a week yeah once a week cubes grow
back then you shave one side like this
you get to shave one side and you keep
this one longer the next person
they have to live in the back of the
restaurant and eat cubes
and then they have to lick the dishes
the floor
everything with their tongue to clean
there's a guy in the back whose only job
he doesn't even cook he just grows his
hair
waiting for the next culprit it's
asthmat
borat sidekick can you imagine that dude
how does the mentality work though like
first of all if you were to just grab
i don't know like eight hairs and then
just lay them on top
that's not gonna be like a successful
you know
right like you would maybe one two hairs
you know what i'm saying what a [ __ ]
con they almost got away with it because
then
when they brought it up to the you know
the the staff they're like oh there's
there's hair in here like
we're you know like we're not paying for
this you know and already that's
it's just like what the [ __ ] right um
what's so bad about hair anyways though
true i guess it's the amount of hair
there's two two fistfuls of
puberty i see hair in my food i just go
oh [ __ ]
true i'm the same way too if i see a fly
i'm just like whatever what about the
type of hair though
like if it's like it's like a long hair
it's it's gross but it's like oh [ __ ]
yeah but it's like like curly i'm
angrier if the food sucks yeah if it
tastes good i don't care if the food's
bomb
and it's the curliest of pubes like i've
ever seen i'm like i don't really care
if the food sucks and there's like five
pieces of hair
oh that's true even if my own hair falls
into the dish i'm like
your own hair yes no way i can't
i get really gross do you ever like just
put your hair in your mouth
and then like try to desensitize
yourself like an irish lord
i'm exaggerating but no like every time
i do see if i do see a hair on my plate
i have to tell myself it is and and then
like that's when i try to psych myself
out but yeah like i i can't do it it's
all curly you're like all right it's
casey's that's right
oh [ __ ] it must be mine
butthole hair he has blonde hair there i
just feel like this is this is just poor
delivery you know what i mean like you
don't scoot your chair back to do it you
got to be way more so you got to be like
in like a different league yeah you got
to like counter
yeah you got to counter it while you're
under the table and then when you pull
one
out too you got to like pretend like
your hands are doing something else you
know for like a minute or two
your experience have you done maybe
before and then from there even if you
are springing you're like reaching
somewhere else for like misdirection
yeah right cause you're sprinkling this
way oh that's good okay
and then after you do that too there's
like a mixture of the food so it's under
oh right like you can't just leave it on
it's like we ate our whole meal but now
we just noticed and complained about it
yeah you have to like mix it in right
yeah
and then you have to counter as well and
be like look i honestly i just feel like
it's weird to like pay for this like uh
you tell us what to do you like put them
in the position you don't be like yo i'm
not gonna pay for this
but then what if they go yeah you have
to pay the ninety dollars well if
they're like we'll give you a discount
then then just be like alright cool take
the discount you are going to get a bad
review on yelp everything like that just
letting you guys know like that's just
fair
yeah yeah you sound experienced way too
no i'm just clever for you i'm just
street smart when it comes to pews
it's different sounds like you've done
business in china before my friend was
eating nachos
and then a piece of metal came out of
the nacho
and then we just ate around it and then
my other friend was like
we got to tell them and i was like ow
what are they going to do just give us
another nacho it's like i already paid
for it and he's like no
but like think about other people like
what if there's other plates with metal
in it oh true
i don't care about other people wow i
wasn't even thinking about that and then
he went and he
and then basically it was a piece of the
wire from the fryer
you know like the deep fryer oh like the
fire was breaking apart
like this yeah the basket a piece from
that was
inside the uh knockout wow that's crazy
i guess they make the chips fresh that's
nice there we go that's a good way to
spin it i really like those baskets too
because you know they like they lock in
yep
the deep fryer oh yeah they make so many
good deep fried things like that
but yeah so these guys they they pull
that stunt uh the manager comes out
looks at investigates the dish and he's
like oh sure enough there's a pubic hair
in there
that these people he thought something
was fishy because he was like like you
said
he's right on top it's just right on top
it's not mixed in or anything
who [ __ ] sprinkles it like or like
like [ __ ] it's parsley
that's who salt bait the [ __ ] pubes
dude that's what went
ah yeah so then he goes back to the back
room
and looks at the cctv oh and sees this
footage
time to lock the doors and call the cops
he did not call it
he did call the cops but uh when he went
to uh
go to them and like talk it out or
whatever they go into a
timid argument in that time conference
ten minute argument
how does he argue against proof like
that
if you want to be right you you're gonna
find a way to
you right there [ __ ] with them though
just to waste time for the cops to get
there it's like hey let's not tell him
we have the footage let's just see how
he acts
[Applause]
true right yeah i'm not going to show
you the footage but i'm just going to
see how much of a douchebag you are
right now i'll just be like dude i think
that's your own hair that fell into the
stuff
no why would you choose bring out all
the cooks but hey let me see your pups
no check pube check no
you are potential you stay in this line
all of your cooks
were red heads it's just all the same
hairs
just imagine the guy's face is like all
because kind of like one red
red red [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where do you think this came from huh
blondie
yeah he's so fun that's true they get
arrested or whatever
they actually walked away from this
situation so so
what yeah so this this is in california
and then the restaurant owner owes them
money sounds about
california california in california yes
that sounds about right too california
law
now this is uh in london takes place in
london and
the argument ended with the the two
patrons
throwing 26 at the restaurant manager
not even half the price of the meal and
just threw it at them and they followed
the cops
no the cops didn't get there yet oh like
it just took them a while to get there
and so then
they they walk away and people still
don't know who these people are yet
so oh man we have their dna the puke
true
true
what a bunch of cons man like how low do
you have to be
to steal their food cubes they like
taped other people's pubes to like
they're inside oh
wow they're ahead of the car double con
wow wow
dude stealing food i feel like that is
so low unless you're like aladdin and
you need an apple
because you're just dying and [ __ ] right
these guys don't look like they're
starving
they just look like [ __ ] heads yeah yeah
yeah and i
wear the pandemic too right and that's
that's another situation is that hey
every restaurant is struggling
everyone's struggling
we should find them and [ __ ] them up i
think that's better than
they paying a fine or anything mm-hmm
just i'm just giving you
justice yeah i think they should get
their asses beat because they just
other people's pews i think that'll be
hilarious while they get their asses
beat
yes i really want their asses to get
beat yeah i want to like jack them off
so this dick gets like why do you want
to please um
give him time give him
okay babe and then i paint his dick like
a cucumber okay
and then i get a peeler and i start
peeling there we go there it
there it is paid off it paid off to be
patient like bolton [ __ ]
okay mm-hmm bolton yeah i haven't heard
that name in a while
you